the Jacobs great to have you here
tonight and the season four premiere of
Game of Thrones in the UK now of course
we're looking forward to seeing grey
worm back on the small screen what
advice would you give your character for
future seasons though stop taking life
so seriously it's not that bad
no he's been for a lot I think maybe I
wouldn't say that a bit insensitive I'd
know in fact you know what I would say
in a more sensitive way I'd say like
look look at the Sun and look at like
the beautiful things in life enjoy it
you're free his kind of journey in this
season is like developing a human side
to himself but I think he's very very
much got kind of slave mentality drilled
into his brain is such a deep trauma
he's a very difficult thing to him to
overcome but um yeah I think that that's
definitely something this that he's
starting to feel more now it's that
sense of freedom which he never had I
haven't read the book I'm an unsullied
both the name and in I'm an unsullied in
every way I just didn't have time
between like finding out I got the part
and then doing the show I wouldn't be
the only reason I read it by that's the
thing I don't want to read it to find
out what happens in the show for me I
want to read this because I want to know
what you know all the fuss is about
and Ian Michael a knee he plays
Barristan Selmy
let's read all the books and the way he
talked about and makes me want to read
really bad
yeah
you